-You grew up in Manhattan.
Live in L.A.
Is it weird to come back?
Has Manhattan changed a lot
since you were a kid?
-It changed a lot,
'cause I grew up in the projects
on 16th Street and Ninth Avenue.
And back in the day
it was the hood.
And now it's called
the Meatpacking District.
[ Laughter ]
My street cred
is completely gone.
-Yeah.
-It used to be like,
"Yo, I'm from Chelsea!"
And they're like,
"Tsk, the Meatpacking District?"
[ Laughter ]
And it's funny 'cause, you know,
my mom and my dad
used to always say, "Y'all
better buy some property."
And, you know,
we don't listen to parents.
They're parents.
-Yeah.
-So, you know, they're like --
my mom was like,
"You should buy this property,"
and everything was so
dilapidated and messed up.
You know, she would be like,
"You see that crack house
over there?
That's gonna be New York's
hottest hotel."
[ Laughter ]
And it is.
-Yeah, it is.
[ Laughter ]
-Called the Soho House.
-Yeah. There you go.
-"You know that railway station
up there
with all the dead bodies
and the weeds that grow?
That's gonna be something called
the High Line."
[ Laughter ]
"You know that bodega?
Yeah, with all the stale food?
Whole Foods!"
[ Laughter ]
I should have listened.
-You should have listened.
-I'd be a billionaire right now.
-So, this show is based on
your real life.
It's about raising two kids.
-Yes.
-With your ex-wife.
So this based on not only you,
but them.
-Yes.
-How do they feel about being
portrayed on a television show?
-Oh well they -- I mean, you
know, they're scared to death.
'Cause they signed their life
rights to me, basically.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And they're teenagers.
I just tell them,
"Don't do nothing stupid,
and it won't get in."
[ Laughter ]
"'Cause I will put your business
in the street."
You're gonna see like --
'cause they're teenagers.
It's gonna be like,
"On a very special 'Marlon,'
Shawn smokes weed."
[ Laughter ]
"Amai gets pregnant -- again."
It's -- it's gonna --
it's gonna be all bad.
-How do they feel about
the actors who are playing them?
-You know, my daughter likes
the girl because she's like,
"She's smart like me."
And my daughter is really smart.
Like, she's gotten all A's
her whole life.
She got one B and she cried.
I got one B in my life,
and I cried tears of joy.
I was like, "I got a B!"
[ Laughter ]
And my son, he's like,
my boy is like,
"I don't like the boy, Dad.
He don't remind me of me."
I'm like,
"Shawn, you're too cool.
You'd get me canceled.
You can't just be this."
[ Laughter ]
"That's not gonna work on NBC.
The kid is funny."
-Yeah. So you had to get --
you got to get somebody
who was a little more energetic
than he is.
-Yeah. Relaxed.
My son got too much cool on me.
And then, his mom -- their mom
is always wanting to, like,
give notes on her character.
She's like, "I don't know
if I would do that."
I was like,
"Look, this ain't your show."
[ Laughter ]
"This show is called 'Marlon.'
When we do 'Angela,' you can
give that character notes."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, you embarrass
your kids on the show.
Is that something --
Are you a father who
embarrasses your kids
in real life?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
From the beginning?
-I just do it to be --
Yeah, from the beginning.
That's when you're supposed to
start that.
I love my kids, but, you know,
I just think that
it's fun to embarrass them.
Okay. Like when they graduate,
like, from school,
it's a big accomplishment.
And I get really happy.
And so my daughter
goes to get her --
she graduated from like
fifth grade
and all the parents, you know,
they get quiet and --
I got up on the chair
and I said,
"I know you ain't dumb!
I knew it!
I knew were you smart!
You gonna be somebody!
You gonna be somebody!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then
when they were younger --
This is just messed up.
When they were younger --
you know we had these readings
at their school where parents
come and they read.
-Yeah, of course.
-So I was like, "All right.
Cool. I'll come in and" --
And I read, I'm animated, right?
So I decided, you know,
one year I'm gonna read
"We're Going On a Bear Hunt."
And so I turn all the lights
down in the room,
and they're in like
pre-kindergarten at the time.
So I'm like, "We're going on
a bear hunt."
And, you know,
"You went through the woods.
We go through the mud.
And then we get in the cave.
We see some eyes."
And we see some eyes
and I had Angela, their mom,
put on this bear mask.
And I said, "And we see a bear!"
And she went "Wah!"
You have never seen children
run this fast in your life.
[ Laughter ]
My son went [Screams]
Two little kids peed themselves.
I was like, "Okay, well,
we shouldn't do that anymore.
No more realistic readings."
-Well, congratulations
on the show.
Congratulations -- you got
a movie on Netflix, "Naked,"
that's available now to watch,
right?
-Yes.
"Naked" right now on Netflix.
You ain't got to get
the bootleg, people.
Although people will bootleg
anything.
You know, they got this thing
called the Fire Stick.
I'm on to all y'all.
-All right.
-And NBC, my show comes out
Wednesday night on channel --
Yeah. NBC.
-NBC, that's right here.
-Yeah.
-Wherever you are.
Give it up for Marlon Wayans,
everybody!
9:00 on NBC.